okay another question from arthur how
should i prepare to be a great
syndicate member in the future in a
perfect world what does the syndicate
become what a great question arthur and
thank you for that
so syndicates for people who don't know
are groups of investors
who can put in a small amount of money
each and then write a big check
to a founder we have the largest
syndicate in the world at the
syndicate.com
4 000 members of them 2000 have made an
investment
our first deal was com.com i think the
average check size on the com.com deal
was 4k
and we put in 328 000 from our
accelerator
when you i'm sorry from our syndicate
when you
invest like this um each individual
investor can take less risk instead of
having to hit the minimum of 25 or 50k
they can just put in 6k
that's our average check size in a
syndicate but when you put 100 people
together for 6k which is our average
you get 600 000 so you guys understand
why this is a really innovative
tool for funding and uh all credit goes
to
my friend naval ravicon who created
angellist and who taught me about this
and a shore fund management my friend
jeremy over there
who also taught me all about this and
we're investors in jeremy's company and
i'm an advisor to
angellist full disclosure uh and so
when you put all this together your
question to me is how do you become a
great syndicate member
in the future number one um you don't
want to be annoying to founders you want
to be supportive founders have a very
hard job
and their likelihood of success is 20
maybe so you're essentially
sending this team off on a mission where
there's an 80
chance of failure and imagine if you
were doing that in another situation
like a war or you know special ops
you would take a lot of care to you know
and you would have a lot of respect for
those people
now this isn't life and death but for
the founders i can tell you it certainly
feels like life and death to them when
their companies fail
i mean i've seen founders um get
seriously depressed
i've seen two or three suicides in the
industry over the last decade
of founders whose businesses were
failing and they just made this
horrible final decision to kill
themselves over it and so
founders need support they need
encouragement
they need a warm ear uh maybe you crack
open a bottle of wine and buy them
dinner
maybe you give them a phone call give
them an atta boy out a girl give them a
you know pat on the back
and be there for them and then support
them but you don't want to be annoying
you don't want to be frustrating
you don't want to be like uh some
screaming maniac which i've seen where
people get all
bent out of shape and you can calibrate
your reaction to bad news and good news
just based on the size of the check
if you put in six thousand dollars and
it turns it goes 100x or 200x
like an investment in com.com would
would probably wind up being a two or
three hundred x maybe even more
you want to sit there and just be so
humble and proud and thankful that
you made a bet that returned 100 times
your money or 200 times your money
and then in the other eight that failed
or the other 16 or
24 that fell in your portfolio just take
the failure
take the loss and understand that you
know you're part of
hitting a big winner and having an
outlier in angel investing is having a
big win
so you got to really manage your own
psychology and you got to be great to
those founders
uh and it really is about time and don't
be annoying just like you probably don't
want to have annoying people in your
life the founders don't want annoying
people in their life and if you're
supportive well you want supportive
people in your life too don't you
so be that supportive warm caring
person is my best advice to you arthur
and i appreciate your question